Look at the sky! Look at the sky! It's a bird. It's a plane.
That's it! Kashika-chan was right next to the cheering squad at the
point where the wind was strongest, and her light, cotton-like
body
combined with the paragliding effect of the wind-swept towel made her fly over the
flower field.  Fairy,
right? Victory is now in my hands.
Since I let go of the towel, there is no glider effect. I
still have to die, so the dragonfly will catch me. The
predicted fall point is not here. I
will catch the person falling from that height.  All of them were
injured.The
recoil from the jump that God gave me left me with some momentum.I'm
glad I made it in time, brother.Marry me.Wow, thank you very much for fighting with me here.Thanks to you,
I was saved.  This is the
essence of female friendship.I'm so
glad I wasn't there.